نتابع اخر ما يصدر من تصريحات فيما يتعلق
بهذه العمليات الاخيره المعلن عنها من قبل
واشنطن وكذلك لندن من تنفيذ عمليات في
اليمن
محمد بالفعل اصبحت هذه البيانات تتشابه
تقريبا بشكل روتيني وشبه
يومي القياده المركزيه افادت بان البحريه
الامريكيه
والبريطانيه شنت هجوم
دفاعا عن النفس ضد سته من الصواريخ صواريخ
كروز كانت معده
لاستهداف السفن التجاريه والسفن الحربيه
الامريكيه في البحر الاحمر في حين افاد
مصدر اخر لاكثر من وسيله اعلاميه انه تم
بالفعل استهداف حوالي 30 موقعا مختلفا في
اليمن لمواقع يسيطر عليها الحوثيون وتم
استخدام سلاح الجو وايضا الصواريخ
المنطلقه من القطع العسكريه في مياه البحر
الاحمر مره اخرى ل بعد ان تاكدت البحريه
الامريكيه ان هذه الصواريخ كانت معده
للاطلاق وتشكل تهديدا عاجلا
على الملاحه التجاريه المدنيه وايضا على
السفن العسكريه الامريكيه في مياه البحر
الاحمر مما حمل القوات الامريكيه
والبريطانيه على استهداف هذه المواقع كما
قلت اصبحت هذه البيانات تتشابه حتى في
لغتها ويبدو ان الولايات المتحده وفي
الوقت الذي تصر فيها تصير فيه على الفصل
بين ما يجري في غزه وبين البحر الاحمر
باعتبار ما يجري في البحر الاحمر هو مشكله
دوليه اي يجب ان تعنى بها جميع الدول
وجميع
المستهلكين في مختلف دول العالم لان
البضائع التي اقتنوها يوميا سترتفع
اسعارها بسبب ما يجري في البحر الاحمر ولا
تريد ان تربط اطلاقا بينما يجري في غزه و
نشاط انصار الله الحوثيين في اليمن